good morning everybody
um it is my aim this morning to try and
persuade any of you have entrepreneurial
instincts to unleash them without
further delay and my name as crow says
is Mike Souter and I run one of the
fastest growing startup media companies
in the UK shortlist media we have grown
from 15 and a half
oh sorry from 0 to 15 and a half million
pounds worth of turnover just in four
years we've grown from five employees
four and a half years ago to 95 and we
have won countless awards actually I say
countless of course I've came to the
mall
we've won 34 awards which I I polish on
a monthly basis I'm at the heart of our
business is a concept which we call
freemium it's the idea of taking
high-quality information and
entertainment and delivering it to
consumers for free and charging
advertisers for the privilege of of
being part of that communication it's
it's something which has in a very
unorthodox way taken the norms taking
the established an understanding of what
magazines do and change that completely
and they're the business model that we
took on has been something that has
existed very successfully for a hundred
years so we did something I'm very
unorthodox with is something very
insurgent and in doing so we have taken
on and beaten the rest of the magazine
establishment um so this is brilliant a
my only complaint I guess about the
whole thing is this is something that I
should have done 10 years ago or 20
years ago instead I built my career and
managing businesses for other people
what I was doing just before this I'm
six years ago I was the editorial
director of Britain's biggest magazine
company it was my job to research and
develop and then launch magazines if you
launched magazines successfully it's a
very lucrative business so therefore I
was on a massive salary I heard a huge
office I had not one but two assistants
I had an army of developers and in short
at that point in my career I was
probably the least likely entrepreneur
of all time because why would you give
something like that up um well I'll tell
you why ah
and that by the way is what we do I ate
something resembling this not exactly
this but something that probably did me
as much damage I ate I ate a chicken
sandwich and later on after that lunch
were ate the chicken sandwich I got on a
plane and I went abroad for a long
weekend but that evening I discovered
that with the chicken sandwich I'd got
some very very serious food poisoning it
was a really really nasty strain of food
poisoning which unless we've all had it
right so I won't go into the gory
details considering it's just before
lunch but over the next couple of days I
got quite seriously ill and this here is
the typhus bacteria which started to run
riot through my system so upon my return
to the UK I was hospitalised in my
condition got worse and worse and worse
and there was a moment and probably
about four or five days after I was in
hospital with kind of tubes coming in
and out of me because this bacteria had
entered my central nervous system with
doctors kind of rushing in and out
looking a bit concerned and my wife in
tears that I thought for the first time
in my rather wonderful and gilded life
that it might be nice to be dead
now I don't think I was ever actually
that close to snuffing it but I suppose
what I'd certainly had was was a moment
which started me reviewing what it was
that I wanted to do with the rest of my
life so a month or so after I started to
recover I saw it's compose in my head
and my resignation letter because I
decided that life was frankly going to
be too short to carry on working for
other people so I don't want you guys
because you are young you are the future
you're incredibly smart and brilliant
and dynamic and whilst I'd like to
employ all of you I'm now going to tell
you eight reasons why I think you should
unleash that entrepreneurial and spirit
and not wait until you are either as old
or as ill as I was reason number one
recessions are great times to start
businesses Disney IBM Apple MTV
Microsoft these are all businesses
extraordinary businesses which started
during recessions driven by creative
people with extraordinary ideas and with
real vision and determination if you
start a business in a recession and it
survives then it's no accident that it's
surviving it's because you've managed to
to create a service or a product that
genuinely responds to consumer need
you've probably got your pricing
structure spot-on and you've definitely
got a lower cost base what this means is
you will have far less competition when
the upturn eventually comes and despite
the fact that there are all sorts of
absolutely horrendous headlines going on
out there despite the fact that there's
a world were in some trouble an upturn
we'll come and when it comes there will
be a rising tide and that rising tide
will float your boat faster and higher
than everybody else's because all of the
people who decide to launch when the
Uptown comes will you'll be one or two
or three years ahead of them if you can
survive the hard times you will thrive
during the good times our business
flourished because of the recession
rather than rather than suffered on it
and it flourished because our
competitors those incumbent players the
establishment had too many problems on
their hands to snuff out the threat that
we posed to them it also meant that they
were laying off really phenomenally
talented people and that they weren't
hiring the best young talent coming
through thus leaving us a clear route to
being able to do so reason number two
the earlier you start the easier it is
the younger you are the fewer
obligations you have families are not to
be too brutal about it a collection of
lovable cost centers my old boss
Felix Dennis a man who has made a
billion pounds from media over the last
40 years or so has a great phrase for
those really costly accessories that you
accrue during your life he says if it
floats flies or fornicates ranked it
what he's done across our time he's a
single man I'm not saying he's a happy
man but he's a very rich man don't wait
until you have things to sacrifice it's
a whole lot easier to stay in the office
to win that all-important contract for
your new baby if you don't have an
actual baby back at home um and you're
also more mobile you are able to pick
your life up I know some guys who but
eight or nine years ago now decided to
go to Vietnam there are a couple of them
to set up a research business one of
them had worked in a research company in
London for three months that was the
extent of the experience and the
understanding and the knowledge that
they had they just knew more than the
people in the marketplace that they went
to they worked really hard at it it was
incredibly hard it was incredibly
exciting and they sold that business but
year and a half ago to an enormous
marketing services group for I think
about thirty million US dollars so they
did not bad out of the concept that you
can just get up and move and go and
create businesses in growth economies
China Mexico Brazil these are
phenomenally exciting and vibrant places
learn to think like an insurgent and
there are two basic fundamental
positions you can adopt in any market
first of all there's the big guy there
there's the does the incumbent and he
has the market share he has the
resources the leverage he has the
customer relationships and he has
capital and these guys are like boxing
heavyweights they are muscular they are
powerful if they catch you with a punch
it's game over but they are a bit slow
and a bit conservative they have
everything but they also have everything
to lose which sometimes makes them pause
and and then there's the insurgent they
have
nothing and nothing to lose the only way
they can win is to be nimble to be
clever to be fast to be creative to be
audacious and innovative the insurgent
is the one that always challenges the
norms challenges the established working
practices and the insurgent has nothing
to lose and it is wonderfully liberating
when you have nothing to lose you become
incredibly focused as I said earlier on
we turned around a business model that
had been going for a hundred years we
created an entirely new consumer
proposition
we created an entirely new offering for
advertisers and we created a whole new
distribution network upon which the
business seats we would never have done
that had we been the incumbents and also
what was useful about that was we knew
that if we succeeded it would be very
difficult or very painful very costly
for the incumbents to respond to that
and to change their own business model
which is exactly what's happened over
the last four years a little knowledge
is priceless and celebrate your rough
edges glory and in the fact that you
don't know everything and you especially
don't know what you can't do this this
van here represents to me
the nationwide hand distribution network
that we set up at shortlist media for
the first six months of my business my
business partner and I spent a lot of
time in vans probably around about the
same vintage as this one around the
country learning how to distribute if
we'd known how difficult it was going to
be we never have started
and we'd still be absolutely at square
one we eventually did it and it is now
our most valuable asset of all talking
about it's your greatest asset as a
young person is that you understand
young people I employ young people
because they know what's going on um
it's a phenomenally effective and
cost-effective way for me to run my
business I'm telling you this so that
you don't fall into the same trap and
your greatest asset is that you know how
young people behave and why they behave
that way you understand why it is that
60% of under-20s would prefer an iphone
to a car you understand why you know the
only way is Essex is vastly superior to
Made in Chelsea you understand why is
that people think that you know Tinie
Tempah is going to be overtaken by I've
forgotten his name now Louis essien and
it's true you don't need to Commission
expensive focus groups to find this out
and my mate Alan sugar and I never
thought I'd say that before has a
central philosophy and he believes that
people should launch businesses in
things that they know well this is what
you know there are lots of anxious
investors out there and and again
despite the headlines out there and they
do exist most startup businesses require
capital at least some seed capital um
and there's money out there it is hot
money and it's looking for a return and
and it's simple maths investors must
invest especially now with their money
in the bank they own an interest rate of
one to one-and-a-half percent and then
they've gotta pay tax on that return
against that inflation is running at
four to five percent so these people are
making
negative return of between three and a
half and four percent this is a disaster
they need you as much as you need them
and then this really your first idea
doesn't have to be the best that you'll
ever have so long as it's good enough
it'll give you the springboard and my
partner and I started a consultancy
business a research and development
business and we won some contracts it
allowed us to employ some freelancers we
got some money in that allowed us to
employ some decent developers on the
staff and then we went from there we
incubated this this unorthodox business
model we wrote business plan we went and
got investment we launched and lots of
hard work later four years on this is
where we are and the consultancy wasn't
and isn't a bad business it's just not
as good as the one that we've got now
and and that's really the lesson if we
had waited then our second idea would
never have happened we'd still be at
square one so to conclude I wish you
three things firstly that you create
wealth and fulfillment for yourself and
that you employ you create employment
and job satisfaction for others that you
don't wait a minute longer than you
absolutely have to that you have a real
sense of urgency to do this and that
finally if you end up in hospital the
nurses are as nice to you as they were
to me thank you and good luck
you